[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
the background of Voldemort's daughter
if you've only read the original books
or seen the original films then you
probably have no idea what I'm talking
about but if you're up to speed on the
cursed child then you will know that
Voldemort actually ended up having a
daughter named Delphine II Delfina's
conception occurred sometime in the mid
to late 1990s in secret at the Malfoy
Manor this meant that her birth
coincided with the events of the
original books we just never had any
indication of it Delphine II who also
goes by Delfy in the cursed child became
the only known living heir of Salazar
Slytherin after Voldemort died in the
Battle of Hogwarts in 1998 her birth was
kept a secret by her parents because
they feared that their infamous
reputations would place her in danger
especially in the event of their deaths
it is unknown what her relationship was
like with her parents or how they
actually felt about her as they both
died while she was still a baby with
that being said she still went on to
inherit many traits from the both of
them as she grew older she became
increasingly cruel sadistic violent
ruthless obsessive manipulative cunning
charismatic the list goes on her
calculated determined and most of all
ruthless nature meant that she would
eventually go on to murder someone
craig boca jr. this swiftly landed her
in Azkaban prison she was fierce
tempered and would easily lose control
if things went awry another trait she
inherited from her mother and father to
me it's always seemed unusual that
Voldemort wanted a daughter particularly
because he always seemed so focused on
himself in his pursuit of power but one
thought I had surrounding that was that
perhaps he merely wanted a daughter to
carry on the bloodline of his ancestor
Salazar Slytherin which would have been
impossible without some form of
procreation
okay so this is where it gets a bit
scandalous Delfina's mother was a
married woman but not to Voldemort I'll
give you a hint she was married -
Rodolfo's Lestrange yes Davi nice mother
was Bellatrix okay so she's married
doesn't her husband care though it is
never explicitly stated it is my feeling
that rude office was very much aware of
the relations between Voldemort and
Bellatrix I don't think that he had any
objection to it because the very nature
of Bellatrix and Rodolfo's relationship
was almost political they are both pure
Bloods that came from supremacist
families and for mainly this reason got
together Bellatrix's attention being
drawn to Voldemort only meant that
Rodolfo's would be able to go about his
business without further distractions or
responsibilities in fact Bellatrix being
chosen to produce offspring with the
Dark Lord Himself was probably a source
of pride for him he was first and
foremost a follower of Lord Voldemort
and a husband to Bellatrix second after
the Battle of Hogwarts both Voldemort
and Bellatrix were dead but Rudolph has
survived and was subsequently sent to
Azkaban after the death of her parents
Delfy was taken in by Euphemia rao who
was offered a substantial amount of gold
unfortunately Euphemia never really took
to her dolphinese are bringing was
lonely she never even attended Hogwarts
as she had very little contact with
other children in her formative years
when Rudolph's eventually left Azkaban
he sought out Delphine and told her
about her true heritage explaining to
her that there was a prophecy that she
was meant to fulfill after receiving
this information her life changed
dramatically she went to great lengths
to meet and save her father even to the
extent of meddling with time so that she
could create a future where he lived
Delfy was curious about her parents
and just wanted a chance to know them
and that concludes the video please
remember to like the video if you
enjoyed it and leave your video
suggestions down below if you guys want
to know more about tell Feeny or this
topic please let me know until next time
you're always our Harry
[Music]